you might have heard explanations of
quantum mechanics that go like this
quantum objects can't make up their
minds sometimes they behave like
particles localized and small and
sometimes they behave like waves
spreading out everywhere
but you should be careful not to take
that statement too literally to be clear
I'm not saying that the wave story of
quantum mechanics is wrong it's not if
you crack open a quantum mechanics
textbook you'll see wave stuff all over
but when a physicist says an electron is
acting like a wave the actual meaning of
this statement is quite subtle both
mathematically and philosophically
whereas when most people hear the
statement the electron is acting like a
wave they of course imagined something
much more concrete that the object stops
being in one localized spot and
literally spreads out in space and waves
about I'm going to explain why this
straightforward interpretation can't be
right you're not gonna have to take my
word for it either you'll see it for
yourself let's look at all of this in
terms of the classic double slit
experiment which is probably the context
in which you've heard the wave particle
duality it's an experiment where you
have an electron coming in this side
then there are two slits that the
electron can go through and finally it
hits the back wall where we mark where
it lands normally we'd imagine the
electrons doing something like this
so that the electrons that make it
through are all clumping up into spots
but when we do the experiment that's not
what we see instead we see this pattern
which looks kind of like a wave
interference pattern
the standard explanation says that in
this experiment the electrons act like
waves the obvious way to interpret that
is that the material the electron is
made of physically spreads out in space
and half goes through each slit as in
half the actual mass of the electron
goes through this side and half through
the other then these two waves can
interfere with each other and this
interaction causes the interference
pattern
here's the first problem though with
thinking of the electrons as literal
waves if the electron is in fact
spreading out like this then where does
it touch the back wall in one spot no
right it's smeared over the whole thing
but that's not at all what the data says
each electron turns up in just one spot
on the wall
but there's a way to explain that in the
wave-particle duality story as well the
electron was a wave when it wasn't being
observed
but then when it gets observed it
becomes a particle again and therefore
it shows up in just one spot on the wall
but think of what that would mean the
electron before it's measured is spread
out everywhere but as soon as it's at
the wall it has to pick up its mass and
pull it all back together moving mass
takes energy where's that energy going
to come from
not to mention other issues like if the
electron has physically spread out far
over space and it needs to pull back
into the spot very quickly then this is
potentially breaking speed-of-light
constraints the point is the electron is
not physically splitting up and
spreading out but then what exactly is
it doing the theory of quantum mechanics
is supposed to answer that question but
it kind of doesn't the maths of quantum
mechanics doesn't talk about what the
electron itself is doing at all instead
it talks about something called the wave
function of the electron this is a
mathematical function that spreads
throughout space and in this experiment
happens to look very wave-like but it's
important to remember that the wave
function isn't the electron itself and
it's not a physical wave when a
physicist says that an electron is
acting like a wave in an experiment what
they mean is that the wave function
looks wave-like if you can calculate
what the wave function of an electron is
then you can figure out where the
electron is likely to turn up but what
is the wave function and how is it
related to the electron at all does the
electron just disappear when it's not
being measured and only the wave
function exists these are questions that
quantum mechanics doesn't yet have the
answer for which is why this part of
physics has so much philosophical debate
around it we don't fully understand what
quantum mechanics is trying to say about
how the world works
whatever it is it's not as simple as
saying that objects are sometimes acting
like waves and sometimes like particles
hey so thanks for watching I know I
didn't go into too much detail on things
like the wave function and just quantum
mechanics in general but hopefully I'll
be making more videos about that and
hopefully soon if my PhD goes better
this month than it did last we'll see